shoes after that  glorious plug  the album one oh no he did it oh  no he didn't break down greg brown  greg brown  [Applause]  that takes guts  he's up there through the legs dunk  contest  give him the trophy  showtime  brown through the legs  and the dunk  got everybody in their feet here  in las vegas brown has got the attention  of lebron james check out this tweet  greg brown the third my goodness on the  break though that's what i said bro  through the legs  slamming it down  he could have pulled off another move he  rose up so hot that was just crazy in  the middle of a summer league game  all tens  we give the dunk contest we just saw  there all tens give that man the trophy  that was crazy it's crazy because  like people fool around with that an  open gym even in a dunk contest you  might not even go for that in the middle  of a real game i mean  we weren't ready for that